with year five season 3 just around the
corner I thought it would be a good time
for a quick catch up on what happened
the last time we were in New York and
where I predict the story could be
taking us titled Vanguard we will be
uncovering the truth behind Ken's
motivations in his final
[Music]
days following the events on Coney
Island where Kina had essentially set up
the Black Tusk to be ambushed by the
cleaners and the division were able to
move in and rescue fatali trinko a
distress call was received from the
division command in lower Manhattan City
Hall had been attacked Agents from
Washington make the way to New York the
attack left the building completely
destroyed and contaminated by a new
unknown virus through video surveillance
it is found that a group of Rogues led
by Aaron kenina were the ones
responsible for all those months after
after abandoning the L&B in New York Ken
had been forcing velli to create a new
weaponized version of the virus called
eclipse and with his new virus his next
step was to build a cell of Rogue agents
to help carry out his plan first Vivian
connley with the offer of Vali trono's
whereabouts on Coney Island she and her
cleaners were already well under the
thumb of Kina next was James dragov he
would be brought on board along with his
new family the Rikers dragov was
completely uninterested in joining his
cause however he quickly changed his
mind when Kina started executing Rikers
and threatening to continue to take them
down until dragov complied kenina needed
access to the supplies drov was able to
acquire and the ability to move them
undetected through the city following
this kenina approached Theo Parell a
master hacker and Tech genius he was
able to persuade him by providing
evidence backing up Theo's growing
suspicions around his father's death and
conveying to him that people higher up
had shown not to have the best of
intentions for the people and that the
division was was
corrupt finally there was Havier kajika
kenina enticed kajika to join him by
offering up the names of the people that
betrayed kajika and his Squad during a
previous
Mission so now he had his team their
first job was to launch a collection of
biological attacks on sites around New
York City and these included City Hall a
number of highly populated areas and an
assortment of jtf facilities and it was
this Catalyst that led to the acting
commander of the division in New York
faao to request urgent help from the
agent in Washington
DC undeterred by the division's search
for him Kina continued with his
preparations with Pell's technological
expertise and drag off's uncanny ability
to provide him with a number of
high-tech materials Ken's plan started
to become a reality the rogue agent
network was built along with more lethal
forms of the shd tech and ground to a
missiles that would Aid in spreading the
virus with his plans now in full swing
Ken had very little need for his team of
Rogue agents anymore and allowed the
division to take them down one by one
they had served their
purpose as a result from the Intel
gathered from the Rogue Watchers Fila
was able to pinpoint Ken's location on
Liberty Island the agents quickly barded
a fury and proceeded to Ken's location
but the Black Tusk were also looking for
Kina and on the way to the island
launched a missile attack aimed at the
boat and were successful in destroying
it however the agents survived the Black
Tusk then sent Ground Forces to stop
Kina including a Razorback missile Lord
but the agents were quickly able to
overwhelm their
forces throwing in everything they had
left the black task sent in a Marauder
class quadcopter and a number of
warhounds to kill Kina and any remaining
agents on the island but Ken's new more
advanced shd Tech was able to hack the
quadcopter and warhounds and he turned
them against the
agents the agents were successful in
stopping the Hacked forces but now that
all Black Tusk forces on the island had
been eliminated they had no choice but
to abandon the attack leaving Kina and
the division agents to finish the
fight fighting through keen's heavy spam
of shd tech the agents eventually
cornered him on the outside of the
island where he was preparing to launch
his missiles containing the new virus
with only seconds to spare the agents
were able to destroy the missile
launcher kenina then launched a head-on
attack however it was during this attack
that he was heavily wounded he managed
to escape to the pier but his injuries
proved too much the division agents
caught up to him and before they could
stop him he activated his rogue agent
Network telling the agents that they
have no idea what is coming before dying
shortly
after we would find out later on that it
wasn't so much that Theo had created a
new rogue agent Network called Anna just
that he had managed to learn of its
existence and unlock access to it as we
now know Anna was built at the same time
as ISAC and is actually Superior in many
ways and would end up being Ken's gift
to other agents who had lost faith and
those who are calling the
shots the end of the Warlords of New
York campaign left us with many
questions including Ken's huge
personality shift the fact that he has
always been two steps ahead of everyone
around him yet he was easily tracked
down to Liberty Island and what was his
purpose behind the missile attack that
the agents were about to stop well I'm
hoping that year five season 3 will be
able to answer a few of these questions
but there has been a lot of Intel drop
since Warlords of New York so I'm going
to throw out my prediction of where this
season could be going a lot of these
thoughts of touched on an earlier
speculation but with the new information
over the last few months I feel like I
may have actually been a little closer
than I'd
thought I'm just going to go out there
and say it all of my videos about Kina
and the hashtag I've been posting over
and over Kina was right I think this is
how things will play out it's not that I
think we're the bad guys and that Kino
was the good guy by any means more that
he was a sort of anti-villain that his
goals may have had some nobility behind
them but his methods of getting there
may have been a little bit well maybe
more than a little bit evil regarding
his personality shift he started out
shortly after the outbreak as highly
intelligent incredibly sure of himself
with determination and perseverance
after turning Rogue his Outlook changed
as he believed that the rules and laws
that used to govern them no longer
existed and that the only way to survive
is by being the one in control and as a
consequence of this he began to use his
abilities in manipulation and influence
to push others into to achieving his
goals audio logs in Washington DC showed
that he had started to develop a bit of
an ego and later on in lower Manhattan a
huge superiority complex was beginning
to emerge with an even greater thirst
for power so why the sudden
change I think this ties into the other
question we've all been asking Keno was
always two steps ahead of the division
and everyone else why would he so easily
be tracked down and trapped on an island
with no backup plan other than to take
on the division face to face this really
didn't fit in with everything else we
seen from him up until this point I
think he needed to act in that certain
way in order to recapture the division's
attention up until this point the
division had been investing a lot of
their time and resources into finding
Kina and maybe in order for them to
finally see the big picture he needed to
eliminate himself from the scenario with
kenina gone the true enemy would be
revealed we need to remember at that
time we were aware of the Black Tusk
they had just invaded Washington DC but
we really didn't know much about them
Kina had always been fighting against
the government and any other
organization that mimics the government
like the Black Tusk sure what is left of
the division is a nuisance to Kina but
they have never been his main priority
in his eyes they just hadn't yet seen
the light maybe he knew that he would
eventually have to make the ultimate
sacrifice for the people to help the
right individuals in the division on the
correct path Ken knew far more about
what was happening in the background I
think more than we even know now all
these in-game months later but in the
upcoming season it will all be
revealed with Theo unlocking Anna it's
possible that a lot more was uncovered
at that time through The Descent comms
we've learned a lot about where Isaac
has come from as well as the
interactions between Natalia and Kelvin
long before the outbreak occurred
through the system flaws around the
foundation of Isaac's infrastructure
Theo was likely to have found this but I
don't think this is how Keno was able to
find out about the Betrayal happening
deep within the government he knew about
this long before then we've seen or
heard rather but there are a number of
agents that work directly with Kelvin
McManus long before the outbreak Keno
was a first wave agent and could have
been one of the first to be recruited so
maybe he had some sort of direct line to
Cal and although he may not have been
aware of the full story before
everything went down maybe after the jtf
pulled out of the quarantine Zone before
going rogue he would learn of what has
been playing out in the
background long story short Kina could
have known Kelvin personally and because
of this probably Natalia too he
suspected something was up and kept
digging and then on top of this Theo
would uncover even more detail Kina
couldn't just turn to the agents and
explain what he's found he's a wanted
man they'd shoot him on site plus he was
still putting the pieces together and
how would he know who to trust and know
the irony of saying this about a rogue
agent isn't lost on me but look at the
massive divide throughout the division
ranks and this has really only become
obvious since his death being two steps
ahead of us he already knew the Divide
was there and this is where I'm going to
go a little bit off script here and
suggest that maybe there is a very small
chance that maybe keer and Fa Lao had
spoken not long before we took him out
all these months later it does seem a
little suspicious that she declared
herself as Rogue at that very moment
perhaps there was more to it than just a
super sweet way of ending a DLC but that
could be a story for another
time let's talk about Ken's Eclipse
virus for a second not just the virus
itself but also the missile we were able
to stop at the end I have no idea aide
what was up with him deciding to blow up
the city with this bomb but it didn't
really seem like a very big missile
maybe he never really expected it to be
launched and it was more about getting
the agents to his location or maybe he
had a specific Target in mind the Black
Tusk were after him as well I know he
pissed them off on Cony Island but they
were throwing a hell of a lot of
resource into hunting down a single
Target I don't know I think there's more
to this however if we look at his new
and improved virus for a second this
really doesn't make sense to me and has
been bugging me for a while it was more
deadly it killed faster almost
immediately and it was red but it kind
of seemed like a downscale of the dollar
flu to me Gordon amherst's creation was
so successful because one it had a 90%
mortality rate and two by the time an
individual was showing symptoms it had
already spread to thousands of others
and through this it was able to quickly
and silently spread around the globe
keen's Eclipse virus makes a hell of a
mess killing almost everyone it touches
but other than leaving a heavily cont
contaminated area in its wake that's
pretty much it it doesn't even seem like
a virus at this
stage I really wish that I had another
week to work on this but I wanted to get
it out before the special report that is
coming out in a couple of days there are
so many smaller details that have
happened since the end of Warlords of
New York that I really wasn't able to
research properly and talk about here so
this is a lot more rushed than I would
have liked it to be but regardless as a
summary I think Keno was on to something
and was doing his own thing behind the
scenes regarding Natalia sokova
president Ellis and Kelvin McManus
realistically one of two things happened
at the end of Warlords of New York one
he intended to be caught and killed for
us to see the bigger picture and two
probably the more likely one but
definitely not the way I hope it goes
his luck ran out and we were able to
track him down before he was able to
disappear once again we finally killed
the guy who'd been making us look silly
since day one whichever way it goes I
still think he was working towards
similar goals to us albeit in his own
Twisted way and through this season
we're going to hunt down and reap the
benefits of his
work anyway I hope you found this
interesting and you're as excited as I
am to find out what happened with Arina
it's well overdue thanks for watching
and extremist mice extreme
[Music]
remedia
n